jeering taken during a session of the
Home Affairs Select Committee when you
were hearing from officials also from
the Immigration Minister can you just
explain what was going through your mind
here and why it was the end of a sort of
series of questions where we weren't
getting answers and where the home
office just seemed to be in a complete
mess about arrangements that may need to
be in place for just five months time
and this is about what should happen if
there is no deal for EU citizens both
those who are here already and where the
government's rightly said they will have
their rights respected and will be able
to continue to stay and work but also
for people arriving for the first time
perhaps coming to work and the
government seem to be saying that free
movement would end straightaway on day
one but also that there wouldn't be any
checks on people arriving but then maybe
that there would be checks by employers
but then that they wouldn't be able to
differentiate between checks or new
arrivals and checks on people who've
lived here for a long time and it just
got so muddled and seemed to be so full
of contradictions
they thought we've only got five months
to go surely the home or office ought to
be better prepared and ought to at least
know one earth it's going to be doing
and we still don't know the answer to a
lot of those questions so who should be
responsible I mean I think it was quite
clear during the session that you were
becoming frustrated with the Immigration
Minister Caroline Noakes I mean do you
think she's the right person for the job
I think to be honest there is a conflict
here actually going on between the home
office and number 10 that the sense that
I've got and from some of the reports
and sort of clarifications since is that
number ten is still trying to maintain
that free movement will end on day one
if there is no deal the home office in
practice knows that they've got no new
system that they would have in place no
changes that they could possibly
implement in time and I have the feeling
that actually the Immigration Minister
you know more junior minister and the
officials are a bit caught in the
crossfire on that they know that there's
no sensible decisions being made no
proper planning being done and that's
why they were getting themselves into
such a tangle so I don't actually think
it was their fault so you think they're
effectively being hung out to dry by a
number tad
a conflict between you know number 10 on
the one hand the Home Secretary on the
other and nobody actually from making
proper clear decisions or being straight
with us and being clear about what the
consequences will be and the reason this
matters is obviously it's a big concern
for EU citizens who are here but there's
a lot of other issues for example what
the security arrangements going to be
what the security arrangements going to
be at the border if we don't have shared
information from the EU what are the
policing cooperation arrangements going
to be and we heard from senior police
officers about the downgrade in security
that we'll have the inability to be able
to arrest people who may have committed
crimes in other countries if we don't
have a proper deal in place in these
proper arrangements in place I mean it's
pretty clear that you're alarmed should
we say at the prospect of no deal
actually say five months to go and with
that in mind could you see yourselves
supporting a deal that Theresa May comes
back with well I think clearly no deal
is the worst situation for all of us but
and a bad deal is a better than no deal
but I don't think the country should be
forced into accepting a bad deal simply
because the Prime Minister and the
Conservative Party and if it is to come
deal with authorizing well that may be
the reality so that's why I think it's
really important that the government is
now preparing the option of being able
to extend article 50 because no deal we
clearly cannot accept it would be very
damaging for our security but a bad deal
something that's going to be bad for the
country for the long term we shouldn't
be forced into that because we've run
out of time because of the chaos and
confusion so I do think now this should
be preparations made so that if the
Prime Minister doesn't get a good deal
before Christmas we don't just get timed
out we don't just end up in a mess and
we do make proper sensible plans now to
extend article 50 in those circumstances
to make sure that we can get an
arrangement that's in the best interest
of the country what about the idea of a
second referendum I don't think that
should be the focus at the moment I
think the focus should be on the deal I
think that the Labour Party has the
right position which is look what you've
got to focus on is is trying to get the
right deal of course you can't rule out
things in this very case you'd prefer
see an extension article fit but I think
the right thing we should be focusing on
is trying to get a good deal but if that
is not working out extending article 50
so there's a chance to look at this
again to renegotiate and to properly get
it right I mean a report that Theresa
May is close to agreeing apart that
withdrawal agreement this idea that the
whole of the UK could be kept in an
effective customs union with EU is that
something you'd support I think being a
customs union is really important
personally I think it should be a front
stop not just a back stop because I
think this is good for Yorkshire
manufacturing it's about manufacturing
jobs and trade but you must be focused
the idea even if it's so I hope that
they have made progress to agree a
customs union I think that would be a
step forward but this only still seems
to be about the the withdrawal agreement
in the temporary arrangements not about
the long term plan we need some clarity
about what our arrangements and
relationship will be for the future so
we're not going into this blind and we
also I think need some reassurance on
these security issues nobody's talking
about what the security arrangements
will be we've heard that even if there's
a deal we could still lose access to
some of the really important criminal
databases but if that downgrades our
security we need answers for that as
well so I want to hear the prime
minister talking about security side not
just the trade side and now what to take
you back to immigration where we started
the interview because it does feel as if
policy is somewhat chaotic should we say
at the minute and we've had of course
the wind rush allegations the windows
scandal that happened we've also had at
the recent scandal of some people being
forced to give DNA samples or asked to
give DNA samples is it the Home Office
that's not fit for purpose I think
that's a really big question and I am
very worried actually about the state of
the home office I think we had the Alex
Allen review that was published or the
executive summary that was published
last week which did raise questions
about the advice that was given to Amber
Radha's former Home Secretary but of
course there are also really
responsibilities that ministers have to
take about the state of the department
as well but I think overall
we've just had one set of mistakes after
another from the Home Office the reason
this matters is because these are the
kinds of decisions that have huge
implications for people's lives and
really devastating effects for people's
lives when the Home Office gets things
wrong we're going to be hearing from the
Home Secretary in a few weeks time we're
also going to be hearing from the
permanent secretary as well that the
head official in the department so we
will be putting those questions to them
I mean do you think there is an argument
for example that the Home Office should
be split up and immigration should be
moved to different Department is it too
big personally I do think that is
something that should be looked at but
it's not something we've discussed on
the Home Affairs Select Committee so
it's not a committee view but I think
when you've got all of the issues around
crime and policing we concluded recently
that there hasn't been enough home
office leadership on crime and tackling
crime for example and and working with
the police to support the police and
then you've got all of the issues around
immigration as well so you could look at
different structures but as I said
having not we've not addressed this as a
committee so we don't have
recommendations to make at this point
and I want to talk to you about
something a little bit different in tax
cuts you have calls voted in a very
different way to your party's leadership
about the tax cuts in the budget and why
did you do that and what was your
reasoning behind that well in April
there's a whole series of further cuts
that are going to be made for some of
the poorest families in the country cuts
to in the value of child benefit and
value of the tax credits and so you've
got some of the poorest people in the
country who are going to end up being
hundreds of pounds worse off
and yet the Chancellor's announced this
budget which gives big tax cuts to some
of the richest people in the country
people on a hundred thousand pounds a
year who are going to get hundreds of
pounds back in tax cuts at the same time
as taking away hundreds of pounds from
some of those on lowest income and I
just think that's wrong and we've got a
rising child poverty those in my
constituency who are facing real
hardship and what we need is a plan that
is fair